So now our page has the correct layout.
But we need to make sure that our page looks good on all size screens,
not just this big one.
So let's go ahead and resize it.
You can see it gets smaller.
And as we get closer and closer to the mobile size,
we can see that this image is being pushed off the side of the screen.
I'll go ahead and make it big again.
It's important to make sure that our websites look good on mobile too.
So, we need to make some changes using Bootstrap.
Look through the Bootstrap documentation to answer this question.
Which class should you apply to images to make them resize automatically?
Type your answer in here